la central nuclear de sabor y ya eleva
las tensiones mientras moscú acusa a
kiev de bombardear la localidad donde se
encuentra desde ucrania sostienen que
los rusos la estarían utilizando como
una base militar de operaciones en lo
que coinciden ambas partes es que cada
día aumentan los peligros de una
catástrofe y se culpan mutuamente de
impedir una inspección de la onu la
secretaría de la onu evaluado que tiene
en ucrania la capacidad logística y de
seguridad para poder apoyar cualquier
misión de la oea a la central nuclear de
savory allá desde quiero' si las
autoridades ucranianas y rusas están de
acuerdo el fantasma del desastre nuclear
en la planta ocupada por las tropas
rusas desde marzo ha tomado fuerza en
las últimas semanas desde que la línea
del frente se trasladó a pocos
kilómetros y ha sido objetivo de
proyectiles de ambos bandos costo
un bombardeo podría dañar la central
nuclear es cierto pero lo más probable
es que no fuera el propio reactor el que
resultara dañado
no obstante es posible que se produjera
un accidente bastante grave no al nivel
de chernóbil sino fukushima
desde ucrania que sigue con el control
operativo del lugar el presidente de
lenski criticó la falta de compromiso
internacional suite baja
durante décadas el mundo ha luchado por
un control adecuado de todas las
actividades con materiales nucleares y
la seguridad radiológica y si ahora el
mundo carece de fuerza y determinación
para proteger una sola central nuclear
significa que el mundo está perdiéndose
viendo a los terroristas cediendo al
chantaje nuclear y terrorista entre
cruces de misiles y acusaciones la
central nuclear más grande de europa
continúa siendo objetivo táctico y
estratégico dentro y fuera de ucrania